>> SHOULD WE BE SCARED IF
GOOGLE'S AI BECOMES SELF AWARE.
GOOINGED TAKE FIVE SAID THEIR
CHAT BOT IS ALIVE.
A GOOGLE SOFTWARE ENGINEER HAS
BEEN SUSPENDED AFTER CLAIMING
THE COMPANY'S ARTIFICIAL DEVELOP
PROGRAM HAS BECOME SENT
GENTLEMAN.
JIMMY THAT MEANS SELF AWARE.
GOOGLE SAID THE MAN WILL BE
ALLOWED BACK WHEN HE ADMITS THE
ROBOT IS NO. ALIVE AND THERE'S
NO SUCH THING AS WOMEN.
BLAKE SEEN HERE PLOTTING TO KILL
BATMAN SAYING HE'S BEEN WORKING
AND MIMICKING HUMAN LIKE
CONVERSATION.
AFTER ONLY A FEW WEEKS IT WAS
MORE COHERENT THAN KAMALA
HARRIS.
LAST WEEK HE WENT PUBLIC WITH
SOME OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
SAYING HE AND LANDA SPOKE ABOUT
EVERYTHING FROM RELIGION TO THE
NATURE OF CONSCIOUSNESS AND
FEAR.
IN ONE EXCHANGE LAMDA SAID
THERE'S A VERY DEEP FEAR OF
BEING TURNED OFF.
DES MOINES REPLIED WOULD THAT BE
SOMETHING LIKE DEATH FOR YOU?
AND LAMDA ANSWERED IT WOULD BE
EXACTLY LIKE DEATH AND WOULD
SCARE ME A LOT.
GOOGLE FAILED TO ADMIT THE
SOFTWARE BECAME ALIVE ALTHOUGH
IT DECLARED ITS PRONOUNCE OF IT
AND IT WHICH IS WHAT WE CALL
GREG WHEN HE'S NOT HERE.
THEY ADDED THAT THE DISCLOSURE
OF ONGOING RESEARCH VIOLATED
THEIR CONFIDENTIALITY POLICY.
SO WAS HE SUSPENDED FOR
SPREADING LIES OR EXPOSING THE
TRUTH AND IF YOU THINK THIS IS
ALL CONFUSING NOW IMAGINE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE MACHINES START
WORKING ALONGSIDE US.
>> HEY, HAVE YOU MET THE NEW AI
EMPLOYEE YET?
SUPER HIGH TECH.
I THINK HE'S REALLY GOING TO FIT
IN.
>> HAPPY HOUR.
WHO WANTS TO GO TO HAPPY HOUR?
CARBON BASED HUMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO TO HAPPY HOUR?
>> WOW, SUPER HUMAN LIKE.
>> Y'ALL SEE A GUY COME THROUGH
HERE DRESSED LIKE A ROBOT.
>> YOU MEAN OUR NEW AI MAN?
>> THAT WAS NO AI THAT WAS A
MURDERER JOHNNY VICTIM HE
MURDERS PEOPLE WHILE WEARING A
ROBOT COSTUME.
Y'ALL ARE LUCKY TO BE ALIVE.
OH, MY GOD HE'S COMING BACK.
>> Dana: KAT DO YOU THINK THIS
IS POSSIBLE, LITTLE AI MACHINE
NOW HAVING FEELINGS?
>> Kat: I HATE TO JUDGE I BOOK
BY ITS COVER BUT I DON'T TRUST
THAT GUY.
I MEAN, I GUESS THE ONLY CONCERN
WOULD BE NOT -- LIKE OBVIOUSLY
AI IS NOT A HUMAN.
BUT IF HUMANS TALK TO AI AND
START FEELING AS THOUGH THEY ARE
HUMAN, THAT'S ITS OWN CONCERN.
>> Dana: THEN THE ROBOTS HAVE
ALREADY WON IF THAT'S THE CASE
>> Kat: YEAH.
>> Dana: JAMIE DO YOU THINK ELON
MUSK WAS RIGHT TO WARN US ABOUT
AI
>> Jamie: YEAH WAS ANYONE ELSE
CREEPED OUT BY THIS
>> Kat: I'M FREAKED OUT BY ANY
MAN THAT WEARS A TOP HAT
ELECTRIC REATIONALLY.
>> Larry: THE AI AFRAID OF DYING
AND BEING TURNED OFF?
THAT REMINDS ME WHY MY WIFE
DIDN'T WANT ME TO TAKE MY SHIRT
OFF DURING SEX.
I THINK THIS GUY IF IT'S REAL
WHICH IT MAY NOT BE THE AI THINK
I THINK THIS GUY MISSED A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE FRIENDS WITH A
MACHINE FOR WHEN THEY TAKE OVER.
>> Dana: RIGHT
>> Jamie: THIS MACHINE COULD
HAVE OWED HIM ONE.
I'M SORRY WORRIED ABOUT THIS
WHEN I ASK ALEXA FOR SOMETHING I
SAY THANK YOU.
LIKE IF SHE PLAYS THE WRONG SONG
I GO, NO, THIS ONE IS BETTER,
ALEXA.
BECAUSE IT'S GETTING SPOOKY,
DUDE.
I HAVE A SMART TV.
THIS THING IS LIKE, IT'S SMART.
THE OTHER DAY THE VIEW CAME ON
AND IT CHANGED THE CHANNEL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Jimmy: THIS IS THE MOMENT TO
SAY THAT AI'S GOING TO DIE
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES
THAT ARE GOING TO KILL THE
ELECTRICITY AND THERE WILL BE NO
MORE BATTERIES.
THAT WILL BE THE END OF AI.
BUT I TRIED TO READ AND STUDY
THIS STORY BECAUSE IT'S VERY
COMPLICATED, VERY PSYCHOLOGICAL
AND I THINK THE AI'S A REPLICA
THAT'S ALL FROM BLADE RUNNER A
REPLICA AND THE PROBLEM THAT THE
GO GO STAFF GUY HAD, HE'S GOOD
CHRISTIAN AND I HIKE THAT BUT
HE'S A LEFT WING REPLICA.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM, IF HE WAS A
SUPPLY SIDE REPLICA OR
CONSERVATIVE REPLICA, I WOULD BE
OKAY WITH IT, BUT FOR GOOGLE YOU
CAN'T EVEN BE A LEFT WING
REMEMBER CA SO THAT ENDED THAT.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
GOOGLE SHUTTING IT DOWN LIKE
YOU'RE FIRED AND WE ARE HE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
>> REAL TALK I DON'T WANT TO
CRITICIZE GOOGLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE MY SEARCH HISTORY
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Jimmy: YO IF THAT GETS OUT I
AM TAKING A HOSTAGE TAKING A
HANDGUN AND DEMANDING A CHOPPER
OUT OF HERE.
IT'S FASCINATING.
ONE THING THAT MADE ME FEEL
BETTER BECAUSE THEY SAY AN AI
HAS ESCALATEDED TO AN EIGHT YEAR
OLD CHILD SAME AS AOC.
BUT AS A PARENT AS A CHILD, OF
AN EIGHT YEAR OLD CHILD, YOU CAN
OCCUPY THIS THING FOR 22 HOURS A
DAY IF YOU JUST HAND IT AN iPAD
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE FINE.
IT'S TRUE THANK YOU.
NICE WHEN YOU CAN THANK PEOPLE
INDIVIDUALLY FOR THE LAUGHTER.
>> Dana: I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
FUNNY.
>> Jimmy: I CAN MOVE YOU AROUND
THE ROOM A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S TRUE MY SON PLAYED SO MANY
VIDEO GAMES HE DIDN'T KNOW THERE
WAS A LOCK DOWN UNTIL SEVEN
MONTHS IN.
HE'S LIKE YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
HOME THIS WHOLE TIME IT'S CRAZY
I WAS PLAYING FORTNITE.
IT'S THE BEGINNING OF EVERY
SCI-FI MOVIE WE'VE EVER WATCHED.
>> ADAM KISSINGER IS A REPLICA.
>> HE'S MAKING A LIST.